hi everyone i'm alan and welcome to my
channel where today i'm doing another q
a for
december 2020. we almost made it boys
this video is sponsored by keeps we will
hear more from them somewhere in the
middle but for now let's get to the
questions also if you want to ask
questions for january
leave them in the comments of this video
because that's how i pulled it from the
last video
that's how the thing works called frugal
said i would love to know the events
that led up to you being hide by santa
monica was it something that has been
building
for a long time yeah you could make a
really boring compilation of every time
that i have spoken about uh
working towards that goal on this
channel for sure um i feel like i've
mentioned it repeatedly over the last
few years
that uh the next step that i wanted to
take in my career was to write a video
game that my two passions have always
been writing in video games and that
i've always worked to combine the two
um and basically the events were you
know i'd already been writing in the
games media side for about eight years
and have always had a passion for
creative writing have done
a significant amount of creative writing
in my career just in smaller ways i've
written books my whole life
i do actually have a couple of things
published you know um i was thinking
about it when people
were asking me and i was like i actually
do i have a poem published in
a coffee table and i think two short
stories have been published as well but
i also worked on some game jams have
written on a number of video
games an animated series uh so basically
it was just stuff that i was working on
very quietly in the background
maybe i was too quiet there's stuff that
i don't feel like i'm quiet about at all
like i studied journalism and
entertainment writing and university i
did that for four years
knowing that the two things that i care
about at video games and writing those
are pretty much the events that led up
to it
uh just a very distinct plan and a lot
of professional efforts to to drive me
towards the thing japanman100 said hey
alana i have a couple of cyberpunk 2077
related questions
did cd projekt red allow you to any
creative input when designing your
character
no i had no control over that and are
you concerned about the possibility of
modders doing odious things to your
character model
no it has been a weird thing to observe
though um
it's like people don't think that i know
how mods work i covered mods
professionally in my career
i covered witcher 3 mods even there are
videos you can still
find the stuff that i i wrote about
those
but no i don't care this is not a thing
that concerns me
even a little bit because it's not me
obviously people make deep fakes with my
my face on them still not me it's
it doesn't bother me in the slightest i
did post some pictures of this recently
but i wasn't
scanned in any way um they had me send
some specific angles of pictures of my
face
i did send them a full body shot fully
closed your jerks
um but otherwise it was actually really
cool process to
you know send off that stuff and then
just be waiting and then get an email in
my inbox one day and be like hey here's
what you look like um
it was really exciting so for anyone who
doesn't already know i can't talk
about it too much yet because of the
embargo obviously which is really close
i'm sure i'll well i have every
intention of streaming the game as soon
as i can
and uh you know probably will post a
reaction to finding myself but um i'm
only available in the nomad life path
uh you will find me i feel i feel pretty
confident in saying that
um but i don't even know my character's
name i don't know if it's alana
it might be i genuinely don't know but
yeah i think um
there are definitely gonna be some
negative reactions thankfully i did have
a little bit of a
experience before then i think i'd done
two games before i recorded for
cyberpunk if i remember correctly
which was in a booth way pre-covered so
um but i i already have had such a
positive response to being involved i'm
mostly just very excited
for everyone to um play the game
completely separately to me obviously
um having played it already myself and
i'm sure i'll see a lot of really
positive reactions
it's time to talk about keeps
did you know that two out of three guys
will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
well the best way to prevent hair loss
is to do something about it
while you still have hair left and i do
know a number of people who've tried
keeps
who basically already had a significant
amount of hair but just trying to keep
it full
keep it luscious and it has worked quite
beautifully from what they've told me
because of the way it keeps works you
can also visit a doctor online rather
than having to go in person and get hair
loss medication delivered right to your
home
very importantly keeps also offers
generic versions of the only two fda
approved hair loss products out there
fda approved we love to see it find out
why keeps has more five star reviews
than any of its competitors and why
hundreds and thousands of men
trust keeps for their hair loss
prevention medication if you are ready
to take action and prevent hair loss go
to keeps.com
alana pierce or click the link in the
description to receive 50 off your first
order
dot that's slash a-l-a-n-a-h-p-e-a-r-c-e
landon campbell said now that you are a
writer for a big video game
congratulations by the way
thank you what is the next big goal you
want to set yourself for the future
don't have to be job related um
i am very goal-oriented i always know
what my next
path is and what i want to do and how
i'm going to get there and the things
and the skills that i think that i need
to get to be able to get to that point
the truth is right now i would like to
write video games for a very long time
um i'm a junior right now so ideally i
move up and then maybe one day i will
direct
i could also see myself potentially
getting into film and tv writing but
i can't imagine ever fully leaving
video games for very long but that's
very far away
very far i don't know outside of
professional goals
um i have been wanting to start a
foundation
or an organization for a particular
thing uh basically like starting my own
charity
um but that is pretty complicated uh in
the us on a visa right now
um they've rejected my business
application already so
that is something that i would like to
work towards to eventually
you know having it be able to run itself
and being able to staff it um
for this particular thing that i would
really like to do but i feel like that's
probably pretty far away it's pretty
complicated
cosignmedi said how do you start your
day off to be this productive also
congrats on the new job seeing a name on
the end credits of new santa monica
games is going to be lit
thank you um i'm actually most
productive at night
is the truth i'm useless in the morning
i don't wake up
and have my coffee and have my breakfast
i i wake up as late as i
possibly can start working have to be
awake for a few hours before i even
attempt to eat breakfast
but yeah not a good morning routine very
productive afternoon night time
is is my truth and has always been that
way you don't want to try to get me to
do anything useful
in a morning let me tell you josh r
asked what's something you'd like to do
in 2021 but you only find the motivation
if we harass you
this is a good one if i can use the
power of
peer pressure to make me do something
okay yeah i'm gonna be honest it's
worthless
what i need you to do
youtube subscribers is um
help me make less youtube videos uh
i have gotten editors which is the only
reason i'm still able to upload the same
frequency that i
was before um i still think that the
amount of streams will probably go down
starting next year it's just we have
stuff that i had planned through
the rest of of 2020 because i planned my
youtube content
really far ahead it will decrease but if
you guys could help me you know if i'm
uploading too much
that's a sign that all i'm doing is
working from 9am
to 2am which is you know i'm not a habit
could you tell me to [ __ ] off please be
like [ __ ] get the [ __ ] off of youtube
nobody wants you here and i'll be like
you're probably right kayla kenny said
hi lana i just built my first pc for
gaming what game would you suggest i
play first on it
kayla that depends on your taste i don't
know you i don't know what you're about
but i'm going to suggest red dead
redemption 2. i was actually very public
about god of war in 2018 being my game
of the year over red dead redemption 2
and some people were very upset with me
for saying that
however red dead redemption 2 is crazy
pretty and i remember the first time
that i played it on pc
um and played around with the photo mode
specifically just being like damn
she looked good so that would be my
loose suggestion not knowing you kayla i
really hope i don't let you down here
i hope i hope i hope i don't mess this
up because you only get one chance
to have the first experience of
something on the new thing and now i'm
nervous
jared whipple asks what do game studios
look for when hiring a video game writer
if i write stories in prose is that fine
or should i show that i can in other
mediums as well
being that i have never hired anyone to
write a video game i have no idea
i can tell you as mentioned i did study
entertainment writing which meant i took
classes on creative writing and
screenplays
and technically narrative design though
it wasn't called that i have written
uh virtually every kind of fiction um
and i submitted something that proved
that i could do dialogue trees they
didn't ask for that uh just
something that i had worked on for
another studio
that uh was a scene full of dialogue
trees which is so much fun to write
i submitted a screenplay short stories a
bunch of different stuff
obviously important to be a good and
experienced writer but your writing will
show that
being a culture fit is important and
also um
especially for any kind of writing the
same definitely applied for ign
as i imagine it would for a lot of game
studios having
a different background or something that
makes you different from the rest of the
team
so that you are bringing your strengths
uh that other people do not have which
is where it becomes something that is um
up to chance up to you being the right
fit and up to you not
worrying when you get rejected someone
else is better for that particular team
or better with that particular style
or in a lot of cases you know for me
going for a junior position
uh at santa monica studio they'd never
want to hire someone who has too much
experience
um that would rule those people out
because then they wouldn't be a junior
but this is a guess as i have not hired
anyone to work on a video game
ross barton said assuming you post this
prior to the event
yes what world premiere announcement or
trailers are you hoping to see at the
game awards
i'm just gonna say what i say every time
all the time
bloodborne 2. gabriel warmbrow asks
what's like your biggest fear now as a
content creator and as a influential
person in the gaming industry
um that there will never be a good
reason
for me to go back to australia
maybe that's not the right way to phrase
it of course my family being there is a
good reason to go back i think about it
every day
but i mean that in order for me to be
with my family i have to sacrifice
uh the entire career that i built which
of course they don't want me to do
that there are no opportunities that
will ever show up in australia that will
be as good as the opportunities that i
can be offered in other countries
and thus i will not live in australia
again
that terrifies me but i'm kind of hoping
that an upside of you know a year full
of terrible circumstances
for a lot of people is that people
working remote
or being allowed to work even in other
time zones
is kind of more allowed across the board
so if i want to go write a
aaa video game one year from home
which i still call australia then
hopefully i will be allowed to do that
evan cashman said how old were you when
you first started to love gaming i was
three or four years old
and when did you want your career to be
based around them um i started
uh my career in video games when i was
18
i might have even been 17. that's when i
started as a writer and then i was a
writer for about three years before i
worked on camera and worked on radio
and then obviously got hired as a writer
at ign it's actually been my job title
everywhere i've worked
except for rooster teeth where
i still wrote almost every single day
this year so yeah when i was 18 pretty
much
i'm lucky to have figured it out early
but again the combination of those two
passions i've always had kind of
made it make sense the hype is picnic
said i'm turned 25 this month and it's a
rough time
what we have biggest aspirations at 25.
um i actually answered this question but
i'm going to answer it for everyone else
i was 25 just over a year ago
and my biggest aspiration was to write a
video game
or to get into games writing at the very
least
so pretty much all of the rest of the
comments
are people guessing
what i'm going to be doing for a living
there's so much g4
i never would have done that it's either
cd projekt right on xbox i replied with
a lull
so funny that was the most common
guesses for sure cd projekt at xbox
she's about to join microsoft
am i all right that is pretty much it i
think i've answered everything else
um which means you know obviously a very
new job focused q a
but hey that's all right it's allowed
sorry i can't give you really any
information though
uh to anyone who's missed it when i
previously spoken about it part of that
is that i don't want to it's really nice
to have a job that i get to keep private
that i don't have to share with the
public i'm very excited about that
it's very nice for me um to have that be
completely separate where previously it
felt like
my professional life was entirely public
because it was so yeah i will not be
talking about anything even if i'm
allowed to
um maybe somewhere down the line i will
but uh not anytime soon apologies
i know that that can be frustrating um
but of course if i feel like there's any
opportunity for me to
inform people or help people in any way
then i will share any information i can
but for now it's off limits stop limit
stop asking
alrighty everyone uh remember if you
want to find out more about keeps there
is a link in the description below but
otherwise i will see you guys next month
bye